can i just jump around because i've not
talked about this at all publicly about
the will smith thing have you talked
about it so much already just a little
bit but uh not since i've actually had
time to like think on it i mean whatever
you haven't talked about it on your bike
no i just haven't i haven't had a
comedian on like we haven't recorded
saying yes and it was like i never also
want to be one of those people that's
like let me give you my take to try to
like
get some clout from like something awful
that happened or like i don't need just
no one is like standing by like i have
to like watch that with myself i'm like
everybody's like getting so many likes
on instagram giving their take i guess i
need to get mine and i'm like no i'll
just like oh i was going crazy on
twitter that night but then the next
days uh gary delabate from the cern show
called like i woke up in the like at six
o'clock in the morning to go pee and i
saw my phone and it was like gary being
like hey could you call the show like
yes i mean i was like i just was like
why did i see do you ever get asked to
do something and you go i gotta do it
because it's such like a great pla like
i can't say no to i just don't say no to
stern so like it would have been nice to
just miss this because i don't know what
i think yet and i'm i have a feeling i'm
going to put my foot in my mouth so yeah
i did say stuff on there that i i'm glad
that i stand by but i'm i have more
opinions on it now i i guess to me i
have like a couple like i just like i'm
all obviously like what he did was
disgusting you know as a comedian i'm
always gonna like play here the tweet i
deleted which i cannot believe twitter
got me to delete a tweet but i did it it
was maybe it just it was about um
like of course the guy
that made a documentary called good hair
is going to go after the bald chick
it was like something in that was very
ironic i know well no it's like what did
you think of court you know it was like
something in that it was just like on so
many levels like like the more i think
about it the more fucked up it gets
where were you when it happened were you
watching so funny i was not watching no
i was like the new yeah where are you
which is so annoying without the chris
rock jokes where were you oh my god
that's so true yeah last night i was at
the store and mark maron was like i was
watching it live and i was like a lot
like i'm like some people saw it live
and i didn't see it live but i think
if i thought live i would have thought
it was fake there's no way i would have
been
i don't know what i would have thought i
think the muting where it went muted
that would have led me to believe that
it was not fake i can't play it back
because chris like seeing him not be
scared at all because the likelihood of
that happening was so
impossible that chris is like what are
you doing man like
hey like when you think about like
the number of steps he the number of
steps he had to change his mind to like
back out of it to turn it into like a
noogie or like i came up here angry but
like and i'll do a fake slap or like a
thing like you you know what i mean it
could have like a lot of bad decisions
yeah the person that just was in 20
minutes gonna win the best actor award
couldn't act like he had his shit
together in that moment like so i don't
think we can even
does anyone remember that he won best
actor i mean like that was completely
eclipsed by this like it it was an app
it wasn't after here's here's the thing
it's a huge deal i will have to win best
actor wild right and that already is
like so that would have been so exciting
without all this like that would have
been such a cool moment will smith r
will smith yeah like
yeah you know
fresh prince uh he's academy award
winning that is an alternative universe
that is string theory like an
alternative reality no my mind didn't
even realize what we lost yes like that
moment yeah that's crazy will smith
summer summer summer
like where were you so tell me
how it went down i was uh well i am in a
see okay so i identify as an addict we
all know that i am addicted to ozark in
a way that is like i'm driving i'm
watching it driving like are you
re-watching it or not waiting
for
here's the thing so the same way if i
were to uh be a drug user i know that
when i do drink sometimes i'll go i'm
gonna skip dinner so it hits harder like
i don't you wanna feel it oh i'll feel
it harder oh yeah you know what i'm
saying so ozark i was like i'm gonna
wait like the only thing
better than ozark is ozark
back
back and like not having to wait between
not having to hear people talk about it
and like sort of like i just i watched
mad men in december what it was if you
thought it was good 10 years ago now oh
my god it's so much better wait so i
like to sit on shows you were watching
ozarks while going driving through an
intersection
i'm
oh yeah so i was addicted to ozark and
then my friend nick comes in and is like
dude and i was like what he's like you
gotta watch the oscars and i'm like when
has anyone said that in the last 10
years and he's like i'm telling you
trust me this is wild and
it he was like careful to show it to me
i was like did someone fall like why did
someone say the n word like you know and
he showed it to me
and i just had this pit in my stomach
and i've had to pit my stomach since
yeah
[Music]
one four four four
[Music]
[Applause]